c'était le 26 novembre 2010 est la liste
de bruno nestor azérot remporté
l'élection municipale partielle de cette
marie mai cinq jours plus tard le 1er
décembre le tribunal administratif de
fort-de-france recevant un rocco contre
la liste de l'ancien député du nord ou
en cours déposée par un collectif
samaritans ils sont sept dans ce
collectif
un groupe mené par régen prises pour ce
collectif sec personnes figurant sur la
liste électorale de buno nestor azérot
ne sont pas en règle
deux d'entre eux ne paierait pas
d'impôts à sainte marie jean baptiste
roads and et jean claude boupda les
trois autres patrick et roger boniface
et franck gilbert-moga d' exercerait
selon le collectif une activité
professionnelle en lien avec la
collectivité samaritaine il demande donc
au tribunal administratif d'examiner
cette affaire ici cet examen est positif
ils réclament l'annulation de la liste à
bourg une restera 0 a été élu le 26
novembre 2010 est une élection
municipale partielle qu'a fait suite à
la démission nombreux conseillers
municipaux
quelques semaines plus tôt c'était début
octobre suite à une campagne très animée
bono nestor azérot l'emporter au premier
tour avec 58,8 % des suffrages
cette affaire de demande d'annulation de
la liste de bruno nestor azérot sera
examiné par le tribunal administratif le
21 janvier prochain